[Music]
maria
is with us in tampa florida hi maria
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris happy new year how are
you guys happy new year to you
we're great how can we help all right so
before i start i want to say
i feel very honored to be on the show
just because i've been listening to you
since i was a little girl
so um i turned to you for advice
um so i took on student debt
a student loans to go to get through
college i'm the first in my family so i
feel
proud that i was able to accomplish that
and
this year with the pantheon like that
hit uh it was a bit
of a blessing and a curse um but with
the
stimulus and everything um payments and
interest got paused for some time and
now with the new
bill that got passed uh everything's
going to start with
a payment full regime of interest um in
the meantime i saved up the money to pay
off
the loan completely and i wanted to get
your advice
on should i pay it off or should i
maybe wait um just to send out what
happens
are you working yes what do you make
um i make six figures
a little over 100k and you're old
26. where'd it go good job
thank you what do you do i i'm a
technology consultant in
analytics excellent okay so
how much is your student loan debt it
is 21 000. and how much you have in
savings
um i have about
25ish
and that's the money that i saved up for
the loan
and i kept it i kept it on hand just in
case
because i ran it was a very odd time
last year
um and then i i'm working towards baby
step number three
uh so that's what they were your major
money one
and your income is stable right now
right maria
yeah okay so guess what it's time to do
you have been diligent you've been
intentional you've saved this money up
to attack
uh this debt it's time to write that
check
it's time for you to not only to become
the first to go to college
but the first one to have it paid for
and that's where you write that check
it'd be a shame to get that diploma
repo'd
yeah maria i'm gonna tell you something
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you some coffee
or red bull or something i need you to
get happy
i need you to get excited young lady
because not only are you working in your
career
and making a good living but you also
have a common sense
the stuff that dave's been teaching to
be able to save up to be able to set
yourself free from this student loan
this is a big deal write a check today
this is a big deal get online and hit
submit
yes are you going to do it yes i am
so once i hit submit i'm officially that
pretty good
i love it
not the way i would have done it no no
but we got there that's right
and uh she is making six figures you
know what she's doing dave she's
resetting
now you guys take she's getting a reset
and how many of you out there have done
some stuff you go boy i wish i could
back up and
redo this thing or fix it guess what
you've got an opportunity
with your money to be able to reset by
making new decisions
having a real plan that works and then
committing to sticking to it
yeah that's all you have to do that's it
so i mean if you
if you didn't get there the perfect path
nope you still got there
that's right and hit reset that's right
and now let's go forward
the shortest path on the right path
that's exactly right